foreign
are you tired of your website which is
buried on the 10th page of Google search
want to improve your online visibility
and attract more traffic to your website
look no further than SEO by optimizing
your website and online content for SEO
you can improve your search engine
rankings and drive more organic traffic
to your site SEO is not just a buzzword
it is a powerful tool that can help the
business of all sizes and industries
thrive in the competitive Online
Marketplace so if you want to stand out
from the crowd and reach your target
audience it's the time to invest in SEO
and watch your website soar to the top
of the search results
as all the online businesses needs SEO a
lot of SEO jobs are flooded in the
market naming a few SEO manager SEO
Specialists are the sum of the
well-known profiles under SEO according
to the data from Glassdoor and pay scale
the average base pay for the SEO manager
in United States is around dollar 76 000
per year however the salaries can range
as low as dollar forty three thousand to
as high as dollar one lakh 20 000 per
year in India the average base pay of an
SEO manager is around 6 lakhs per year
INR however salaries can range from 2
lakh 50 000 inrs to as high as 18 lakhs
per year so if you are looking to grab
such a golden opportunity then you
should definitely look a professional
certificate program in digital marketing
some key features of the program include
master classes by Purdue ask me anything
sessions industry projects and more you
will be benefited from the in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research web management
and optimization URL management keyword
research and more so what are you
waiting for hurry up and find the course
Link in the description box below listen
to what millions of users are saying
about our courses find simply learned
course reviews Link in the description
box so without any further Ado here is a
question for you what is the purpose of
SEO Option 1 to drive organic traffic
option 2 improving online visibility
option 3 improve search engine rankings
option for all of the above let us know
your answers in the comment section
below and get a heart from Simply learn
also don't forget to subscribe simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from simply learn let's
not procrastinate any longer and see
what we have for you in this video
we will Begin by understanding what are
the different types of SEO followed by
what is off-page SEO the difference
between on page and off-page SEO
importance of off-page SEO we will put a
light on link and non-link related of
page SEO factors followed by top 5
off-page optimization techniques also by
the end of this video you will know top
10 best off-page optimization tools and
see the jobs and salaries of this stream
so let's begin with the types of SEO
there are three types of SEO namely
on-page SEO of page SEO and Technical
SEO so let's start with on-page seo
on-page seo refers to the optimizing
individual Pages or web pages to improve
their search engine rankings and drive
more traffic to a website this includes
optimizing elements such just title tags
meta descriptions heading content
interlinking and website structure the
next we have is off-page seo off-page
seo refers to optimizing a website's
external factors that affects its search
engine rankings such as link building
social media and brand mentions the goal
of off-page SEO is to increase the
authority and relevance of the website
thereby improving its search engine
ranking the next we have is technical
SEO refers to optimizing a website's
technical aspects to improve search
engine ranking this includes optimizing
elements such as website speed mobile
responsiveness site architecture and
structured data technical SEO is
critical for ensuring that search
engines can crawl and index your website
effectively we have already covered some
on-page optimization practices in our
earlier videos in this video we will be
focusing majorly on the off-page
optimization techniques or off-page SEO
so let's understand what is off-page SEO
of page SEO refers to the optimization
of external factors that can affect a
website's search engine ranking but not
directly related to content or structure
of website itself this includes building
high quality backlinks to the website
from the reputable ones engaging your
audience on social media platforms
building your own Brands online
reputation through mentions and reviews
of page SEO is essential for
establishing a website's Authority and
relevance in search engine rankings
search engines use backlinks and other
off-beat signals to determine the
credibility and popularity of website
which in turn can impact its search
engine rankings a strong off-page SEO
strategy can help a website to attract
more organic traffic improve in search
engine ranking and ultimately increase
its visibility and online repetition now
let's understand the difference between
on-page and off-page SEO the main
difference between on-page and off-page
SEO is that on-page SEO involves
optimizing the elements on the website's
individual Pages while of page SEO
focuses on optimizing external factors
that can impact a website's search
engine ranking optimizing elements on
website in on-page SEO includes
optimization of title tags meta
descriptions headings content images and
interlinking this improves the relevance
and understandability of websites pages
for search engine however the external
factor in off-page SEO includes link
building social media engagement and
online repetition management so let's
see why off-page SEO is important
off-page SEO is important for improving
the search engine ranking of a website
by establishing its Authority and
relevance search engines use external
factors such as backlinks social media
engagement
influencer Outreach and online
repetition management to determine the
credibility and popularity of a website
getting backlinks from another reputable
websites are critical factor in off-page
SEO as this signals to search engines
that the content on the linked website
is valuable and relevant brand awareness
can be increased with the help of social
media engagement influencer Outreach and
online repetition management so with a
glimpse of its importance let's move
ahead link and non next related off-page
SEO factors link related factors has a
complete control over the links of the
off-page optimization here are few link
related factors that can affect your
website number and quality of external
links pointing to a website anchor text
used in the external link relevancy of
external link to the content of the
linked website freshness of the external
links diversity of the external links
from different domains Authority and
trustworthiness of the domains linking
to the website non-link related factors
have control over everything else other
than the link a few non-link related
off-page factors includes social media
engagement and activity online
repetition management including reviews
and ratings on directories and review
websites brand mentions and citations on
other websites even if not linked
influencer Outreach and partnership
local SEO strategies such as optimizing
Google my business listings and local
directories content marketing efforts
including guest blogging and sharing
content on social media platforms
anyways we are going to cover many of
them in the upcoming part of the video
now that we have gained enough
understanding of what is off-page SEO
let's discuss top 5 off-page
optimization tips so starting with the
tip number one link building
one of the most important of which SEO
techniques is link building which
involves acquiring high quality
backlinks from the authoritative and
relevant websites this can done through
guest blogging broken link building
influencer Outreach and other link
building techniques the next tip we have
is social media engagement social media
platforms provide a valuable opportunity
to engage with target audience and build
brand awareness
by creating and sharing high quality
content on the social media platform
businesses can increase their online
visibility and improve their search
engine ranking towards the next tip
which is online repetition management
online repetition management involves
monitoring and managing a business's
online repetition by responding to
reviews engaging with customers and
monitoring mentions of the business
online by maintaining a positive online
repetition businesses can improve their
search engine rankings and attract more
customers moving towards the next step
which is local SEO optimization
local SEO techniques such as optimizing
Google my business listings building
local citations and participating in
local directories can help businesses to
rank higher in local search results next
and the last tip that we have is content
marketing
content marketing involves creating and
sharing valuable content and relevant
content such as blog posts infographics
and videos by creating high quality
content businesses can attract backlinks
social shares and other forms of
Engagement that can improve the search
engine rankings over time now that we
have understood how off-page
optimization can be done effectively
with these five tips let's now move
ahead with this video to know some
helpful tools for off-page SEO so here
is the list of some helpful tools you
may require during off-page SEO
practices so let's see all the tools in
short one by one let's start by knowing
most most is an all-in-one SEO tool that
can help businesses with keyword
research link building online repetition
management and much more it provides a
range of features for tracking rankings
analyzing backlinks and improving
website performance the next tool we
have is majestic Majestic is a link
building tool that provides
comprehensive backlink data and other
SEO metrics it can be used to identify
New Link building opportunities and
monitor competitor backlinks next we
have is ahrefs ahrefs is a powerful SEO
tool that can help with link building
and competitor analysis it provides
comprehensive backlink data and other
SEO metrics that can be used to identify
New Link building opportunities next
tool we have in the list is semrush or
formally known as sem Rush semrush is an
all-in-one SEO tool that can help with
keyword research backlink analysis and
social media engagement it provides
valuable insights into websites off-page
SEO performance and can help businesses
to optimize their online presence the
next we have is ninja Outreach ninja
Outreach is a tool that can help
businesses with influencer Outreach and
Link building it provides a range of
features for finding influencer in any
Niche managing Outreach campaigns and
tracking results next tool in the list
is pitch box pitch box is a link
building an influencer Outreach tool
that can help businesses with
personalized Outreach campaigns it
provides a range of features for finding
link building opportunities managing
relationships with website owners and
tracking performance to the next tool
which is Buzz stream bus stream is a
link building tool that can help
businesses streamline their Outreach
efforts and manage the relationships
with influence answer and other website
owners
provides a range of features for
managing link building campaigns
tracking progress and monitoring
performance the next tool we have is
Google Alerts Google Alerts is a free
tool that can be used to monitor
mentions of a business or brand online
by setting up alerts for Relevant
keywords businesses can stay on the top
of their online repetition and address
any negative comments or reviews in the
timely manner next tool we have is
hootsu HootSuite is a social media
management tool that can help businesses
to manage and schedule their social
media content across multiple platforms
it provides valuable insight into the
social media engagement and can help
businesses to improve their overall
social media strategy and coming to the
last tool in the list is mention mention
is an online repetition management tool
that can help businesses to monitor
their online mentions across social
media new sites and other platforms it
provides real-time alerts and advanced
analytics to help businesses manage
their online repetition so these are
just a few examples of many off-page SEO
tools available depending on your
specific needs and goals there may be
other tools that are better and suited
to your business now that you know the
roadmap to become a successful Optimizer
these are just a few examples of many
off-page SEO tools available depending
on your specific needs and goals there
may be other tools that are better
suited for your business now that you
know the roadmap to become a successful
Optimizer let's have a look at the jobs
and salaries for off-page optimization
rules of page SEO jobs can vary
depending on the company industry and
location some common job titles in this
Fields include link building specialist
SEO Outreach coordinator digital
marketing specialist and content
marketing manager salaries of off-page
SEO jobs are widely depending on the
factors such as experience job title
location and the company size in general
the entry-level positions may start
around 1.35 000 to Dollar forty five
thousand per year while more senior
roles such as SEO manager or director of
digital marketing can earn up to dollar
one lakh per year as in U.S however in
India the salaries of off-page SEO jobs
may vary the entry level positions in
off-page seum start around 2.5 to 4
lakhs per year in Indian currency INR
while more senior roles such as SEO
manager and director of digital
marketing can earn up to 10 lakhs INR
per year or even more so concludingly
off-page SEO is an essential component
of any successful digital marketing
strategy by building a strong online
repetition and acquiring high quality
backlinks from authoritative websites
business can improve their search engine
rankings drive more organic traffic to
their website and ultimately increase
their revenue with the help of effective
off-page SEO techniques and tools
business can stay ahead of the
competition and achieve a long-term
success in the Online Marketplace with
the help of effective off-page SEO
techniques and tools businesses can stay
ahead of the competition and Achieve
long-term success in the Online
Marketplace so here we've wrap up this
tutorial on off-page SEO if you like
this video do like share and subscribe
meet you soon with another interesting
video on SEO by simply learn thanks for
watching this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you